hi parents are you looking to put a
fresh spin on story time or maybe you
want to make bedtime more fun engaging
and personalized I've got something
you're going to love meet K Migo's craft
a story feature let me show you how it
works first we choose a genre maybe it's
a thrilling adventure or whimsical fairy
tale I want to write an adventure story
then you can co-create a story with your
child about their favorite topics
dinosaurs princesses
space exploration you name it and the
best part is that the story can star
your kids or their favorite friends so
let me show you I want my story to Star
Princess mea and her trusty Kitty
now you'll see that kiga will help you
craft a story star Mira and Ma then
after you finish the story you can enjoy
the Bonnie experience with your kids as
you read the story together if you feel
like creating another Masterpiece you
can go right ahead or maybe they want to
hear the same story over and over again
and craft a story is just a small part
of what comigo can do you look here
there are many different things we offer
um from tutoring Math and Science and
Humanities to brainstorming College
admissions essays to debating different
topics or even chatting with literary
characters and historical figures so are
you ready to start personalizing your
own stories click the link in the
description below to get started with
k